que ce soit au d'accueil ou menuisier ce
parc d'accrobranche situé à saint
germain en laye recherche actuellement
des saisonniers surtout pour la période
estivale les week-ends on recrute tous
types de saisonniers pour faire de
l'accueil client de la pose de la mise
en place de baudriers des interventions
dans les arbres de la gestion du snack
ou recherchent également des menuisiers
pour faire de la maintenance des
élagueurs et donc tous types de profils
de saisonniers sont extrêmement demandés
recherché il existe deux parcs accroc
campent dans les yvelines ces deux
établissements recherche une dizaine de
personnes pas facile pour lui de trouver
les bons candidats c'est plutôt
difficile à recruter on met des annonces
sur la plupart des grands sites de
recherche d'emploi mais pour autant ça
reste compliqué donc on est obligé de
mettre des annonces à l'entrée de nos
parcs on cherche également des
responsables de snacks on veut vraiment
développer nos snacks et on a beaucoup
beaucoup de mal dans le domaine de
l'alimentaire de la restauration à
trouver des responsables de ce match
dans cette salle d' escalade à montigny
le bretonneux l'assistant rh commence en
ce début mais également le recrutement
des emplois saisonniers ont cherché
entre une ou deux personnes entre juin
et août
plus pour restaurant accueille bas c'est
entre juin et juillet c'est plus pour
renforcer vu qu'à l'ouverture de la
terrasse avec les beaux jours et en
outils plus pour pallier aux congés des
personnes en poste en cdi pour trouver
la perle rare la société post des
annonces sur le site de l'entreprise ou
sur ce site d'offres d'emploi même
constat que pour l'accrobranche le
domaine de la restauration ne trouvent
pas de candidats pour les formations se
battent pour s'immiscer vraiment
beaucoup plus compliqué on reçoit
vraiment pas beaucoup de ces lions
passent par les ducs ou visitez notre
site on a aussi été la restauration ou
du coup la rentrée de plus en plus appel
à brigade ceux des extras pour pallier
au manque de personnels qu'on a
notamment en cuisine les restaurateurs
peine donc à trouver des employés même
problématique en hôtellerie même si ce
secteur ne recherche pas forcément des
saisonniers dans les yvelines en période
estivale c'est plutôt le secteur des
loisirs qui recrutent comme les parcs
d'attraction ou visite de loisirs